o iPhone wallpaper plena Ponte Estaiada
leite eu vou ver ele é
o som interno sentimental e essas tem
dúvida a minha maior qualidade eu sempre
fui muito melhor escrevendo do que
falando para expressar assim esses meus
muitos sentimentos pouca gente sabe
disso pois Normalmente eles condiz com
muito bem esses mais inscritos sabe
guardando para que um dia quem sabe eu
tenho vontade de dizer no momento
especial Quem sabe Para uma pessoa que
eu considero especial esse aqui é uma
segunda ter dessa terminei o último
inclusive falando a minha vó Elza e
mostrando a importância aquela te vi na
minha vida e dentro seis dicas de uma
trança que é essa que você fala para uma
sociedade fizer pelo normativa Lógico
que eu não vou dar spoiler para vocês
não precisa se preocupar vai ter que
procurar na internet tá aqui não agora
agora te convido a terminar de assistir
porque eu vim te dizer neste momento na
minha última apareceu eu contei que
minha avó Partiu para o outro plano né
então ela nasceu em um outro mundo ela
tá tio e eu e minha mãe para a gente
tava separando as coisinhas na casa dela
para decidir qual né
eu queria que tava falando o quê que a
gente é do ar enfim das coisas tadinha e
dentro dessas coisas que a gente tava
vendo de uma caixa uma caixa gigantesca
e dentro dessa caixa muitos muitos
cartões e cartas nas mais variadas
ocasiões e momentos logicamente você já
imagino que a maioria das cartas era
permitida porque minha aqui né minha avó
sempre foi a pessoa mais próxima da
minha vida se uma pessoa que contava com
vivia muito que eu amava extremamente
faz a pessoa mais difícil para me chamar
de vai ter aliás foram poucas as vezes
que ela me chamou de mais ela chamada de
armas Alessandro mas nunca se vai ter
daí comecei a fazer reagir de falar com
ela eu fiz marra para não ir mais na
casa dela falei que nunca mais escrever
carta para minha avó e nada adiantava
então existe achei que era alguma coisa
da idade que era alguma coisa achar
pouco crescimento na época mas olhando
essas cartas eu fui abrindo aqui as
cartas e foi uma emocionando porque me
surpreendi quando eu vi que quando
assinava esses cartões onde eu colocava
da sua neta Alexandre todos todos ela
Riscado e colocou para sua neta Maitê
a partir de cartas que eu quero falar
com você de uma carta também que eu
recebi um momento muito especial e que
do início nesse novo Fedex é uma das
cartas de suicídio que eu escrevi pro
meu pai pode mais ou menos assim os
trechos
Bom dia me pede da educação em vergonha
do meu sucesso
o terceiro insatisfação agonia não faz
nada e não quero ser nada sem sonhos e
que meros sonhos
e sem poder essa carta você vai ficar
com a pessoa operada e por isso não vou
prolongar o seu sofrimento
me ajude a mãe vai te dar esse problema
da vida dela ela merece ser um pouco
feliz tem um pouco de paz e
tranquilidade Afinal todos no prédio já
estão falando de mim mais uma vez
escrevo Pois realmente me sinto muito
melhor e consegui me expressar melhor do
que quando Faro vou dar um jeito de dar
paz e descer faz com carinho mais tempo
e
o meu pai ele é já se viu ele tem 82
anos ainda só vem antes sem nenhuma
segurança e tem uma proteção sem medo EA
com meu pai que eu aprendi a ser a
pessoa que eu sou Hoje a minha primeira
tentativa de suicídio que os 14 anos eu
esperei todo mundo pede caso querendo
parceira peguei coberta abrir o forno
gás de cozinha o travesseiro eu coloquei
sabe na grelha do Forno peguei um
cobertor que tava frio em Curitiba fez
uma espécie de cabana essa pensei 200 m
a última morada só que
o passada eu não olhei se estragar
suficiente para despedida final E
logicamente só desmaiei e tudo então
voltou ao normal normal que ele não me
acompanhou desde a infância não me
acompanha na adolescência enfim eu tô
com marcas do tempo para sábado em
velocidade mais esses desencontros sabe
comigo mesmo tornava-se estadistas
gigante dentro da minha pessoa a minha
segunda tentativa de suicídio está
chegando quase aos 16 eu morava perto de
uma linha de trem e chega em baixo dele
que me pediria deste mundo aqui para mim
naquela época só trazer desconforto o
mundo ao qual não conseguiram enquadrar
sábado durante um mês eu fiquei
escrevendo amarrar mente placa de
despedida com essas que eu olhei para o
meu pai né Tá alguns familiares algumas
poucas amizades que eu tinha eu guardava
todo mundo gastigo secreto né mas o
local não era tão segura e secreto assim
as capas foram descobertas e eu fui
levado então para ajuda médica Foi então
que ouvi pela primeira vez falar de
e eu fiquei feliz um tempo ao saber que
um dos médicos que sacada na época falou
que uma cada 50 mil pessoas eram como
erro eu falei como grilo nesse sentido a
primeira vez um pouco normal depois
desse médico me deu esse sentimento de
terror que ele fala da escrita e jamais
de cirurgias foi até que fazer e que na
época que eu tinha iniciado eu era ficar
sua fora do Brasil era extremamente
caras e dos Amores também remédios que
tem que tomar vida inteira eu tenho que
ir no médico Porque isso assim o que que
eu não sou como meu irmão mais velho né
o Guilherme o médico mandou me disse
isso é um problema no hipotálamo que
pesquisar e descobri que botar uma
região dia eu dei afeto localizado
abaixo do tálamo e acima de Potter eu
assustei com essa nomenclatura que nunca
havia ouvido falar e eu pedi para ele
dar um banho trocar o cérebro ele viu e
foi então que eu falei de novo os
momentos de depressão aquele cidade
começaram a ficar cada vez mais
constantes nas minhas vidas olha Fish
um pecador licença isso resultado que
foi estudado a vida inteira no colégio
franciscando hoje logicamente eu bebi um
mínimo de água para segurar o xixi para
não ter que no banheiro com medo das
coisas que poderiam acontecer e que
aconteceram nesse mesmo momento quando
era do xixi mais esperado da minha idade
toda me levou Inclusive eu lembro no
centro espírita que me falaram que tem
que fazer uma das coisas que a gente
fazer xixi em cima de um tijolo eu
coloquei assistir jogo muito desejada
por que não imagina quanto xixi em cima
de tijolo e quanto Encruzilhada eu fui
para tentar resolver esse problema
dentro de tudo isso aconteça as
histórias que eu demorei entender que em
todos esses momentos da minha vida meu
pai sempre estava ali presente e atuante
e é dele que o cabo essas questões que
eu quero compartilhar com 2 cm ter neste
momento foram muitas mas eu que sumi
nesse pedex em três grandes ensinamentos
que me tornaram essa pessoa que eu sou e
que eu vou te dar de graça sem você
precisar passar por tudinho que eu
passei olha só que incrível não vamos lá
o número um todo mundo na céu se você
nesse exato momento tá me ouvindo aí do
outro lado dessa tela de computador
parabéns você nasceu Mas a gente não
nascer tendo quem somos sabe mas temos
cheio de adesivinhos que nos foram
colocados antes mesmo de você colocar
sacar piercing dizer olá mundo você já
tinha uma cor que você queria que gostar
você já tinha um time de futebol porque
ele que torcer uma religião que
acreditaria profissão que cês teria e é
bem algumas famílias com quem conseguia
se casar precisa adesivas vou
alimentando-se através de muitas
expectativas que fizerem cada vez mais
fácil em cima da gente mas somos uma
montadas sabe de sonho dos outros de
desejo dos outros de frustrações dos
outros mas eu te pergunto e nós Eu você
afinal quem nós somos esta descoberta
uma das grandes felicidade de ter sido
obrigada a ilha essa pessoa que eu sou
Faria quem sou
a abandonar que a gente acredita ser o
que te fizeram acreditar que você é
barril tem Souza trabalho lado de
autoconhecimento um trabalho de olhar
esses adesivos que nos foram obrigados e
colocados sem nem perguntar se
gostaríamos de pelos e descobrir que
realmente o falecimento da nossa
essência por isso eu te digo valendo
para Nascimento a partir da experiência
de quem você verdadeiramente é isso me
leva a nossa lição número dois somente
sendo quem você é é que você pode
construir um legado da sua felicidade e
do mundo verdadeiramente melhor eu não
sei você se alguma vez você pensou nisso
sessões finja é por não fazer parte de
grupo Nenhum por não se achar para de
ninguém tá sempre dirigir pode deixar
sempre uma pessoa se encaixa esse pensou
você quantas vezes você pensou o tentou
na prática sumir sabe como uma resposta
para dar uma live aí para deixar livre
o que você ama de tanto sofrimento o
suicídio quando você desiste de você é
quando você chega no limite não acredita
que algo bom e útil para a finalidade da
sua vida e o pior é que tem gente
assistência dando todos os dias e vida
não sendo quem nasceu para ser Vivendo
uma vida morna uma vida média uma fake
News a importância de pele ao pai
acredita em mim mas muitas vezes que eu
já tinha desistido trouxe para mim o
entendimento de que nenhum amor
incondicional de que Todo amor tem uma
altura que a condição obrigatória e o
que deixa verdadeiro que a felicidade de
quem esse ano é o que importa EA vida
sinto meu amor nos leva para cima e para
baixo sabe brincando aí no seu próprio
ritmo e velocidade e aqui tá faz isso
com todo mundo não tem como a gente se
catar isso me leva lá na última dessas
visões que eu vim falar pra vocês nesse
meu pé Desce que eu demorei muito para
aprender não importa o que a vida faz
comigo ou com você importa de verdade o
que eu e você fazemos com que a
o meu pai engenheiro civil e as 82 anos
ainda só me enganes e sem nenhuma
segurança tem uma proteção e seria um
merda é com ele que aprendi a ser a
pessoa que sou hoje meu pai caiu no dia
Dezessete de novembro do ano passado de
um andaime de quase cinco metros aos 82
anos de idade foi embora ativo e como é
que faz e a gente não se viu devido a
peneirinha do corrido mas estive com ele
Curitiba dois dias antes dessa queda
comprando pele feliz das alegrias que
estava tendo na minha vida a gente
passou - momentos depois eu cheguei em
São Paulo avisando que eu tinha viajado
bem para ele ficar em paz ele me disse o
telefone assim que achado uma carta que
esta tudo para você nesses meu suicídios
que ele me disse viu só vai ter eu não
te disse que você tinha uma linda missão
para frente que suicídios é um soluções
definitivas para problemas temporários
vou guardar essa cara que ele me disse
para você nunca mais vou usar pensar e
não ser feliz meu pai parte deste plano
o plano no dia primeiro de dezembro do
ano passado foi meu pai a pessoa que
disse que sempre foi uma pessoa e comum
que eu carregava as minhas raízes no
coração e que nos pesa não tinha raiz eu
tinha asas hoje eu entendo mais do que
nunca o que ele quis dizer e além de
voar hoje em dia tem como meta de vir
ensinada outras pessoas que
experimentaram um voo da vida família
Paiva maior exemplo de Que pessoas
memoráveis são aquelas que habitarão
para sempre através dos seus melhores
exemplos de ações e atitudes eu espero
de verdade que essas questões que eu
demorei que aprender possam serviço de
Vento para o início da sua jornada
Olá boa vai sentir o que te espera e que
só você pode viver voa recebe esse
dentro que eu te dei em forma de FedEx
em forma de três aprendizados curtindo
com meu pai vai cair que você nasceu
para ser